good morning Hank it's Friday January
8th 2010 last night our ancestral
homeland returned to its rightful place
among the states Alabama may be 48th in
education but we are first in football
played by people enrolled at educational
institutions yes Hank I want to take a
moment to thank the Yeti for heroically
not going into labor during the game
last night although now I kind of hope
she does go into labor before next
Wednesday so I don't have to get on the
Frog hopper until after my paternity
leave oh my gosh Gary
Hank today I want to talk about Gus who
is a bug but first I have to
congratulate you on spending 15 hours in
target without going insane or getting
arrested the feat that is hardly ever
even accomplished by target employees
however Hank having watched you do this
I feel compelled to point you to a 2008
study about hand dryers link in the
sidebar that's that he shows that using
a hand dryer after you wash your hands
leads to you having way more bacteria on
your hands and if you just don't wash
them at all however that study didn't
have anything to say about pumping that
disgusting air directly into your mouth
so I'm sure you'll be fine
but just know that if you happen to get
esophageal herpes
that's why right so but about Gus Hank a
few months ago I asked nerdfighters to
find my favorite book from childhood
which I told him was called Gus's a bug
and then they did find it despite the
significant hurdle of it actually not
being called Gus's a bug but Hank what
nerdfighters didn't know at the time was
that by finding Gus's a bug they were
actually giving me a baby warming
present I loved that book so much as a
kid that I want to give it to my baby I
couldn't find it anywhere because it
wasn't called Gus's a bug so I turned to
the nerdfighters for help and that
nerdfighters started illustrating their
own versions of Gus's a bug which
frankly I like even more than the
original so with the help of many
nerdfighters I put together this video
book for my baby which will someday be
the babies introduction to the
awesomeness of nerdfighteria Gus is a
bug by nerdfighteria Gus is a bug Gus
has fuzz Gus runs and runs and runs Gus
has fun in the mud Gus nips a bud yum
yum Gus rubs his fuzz Gus rubs and rubs
Gus has a nap
Gus snaps and naps Gus is up Gus tugs
and tugs
it is gus-gus has no fuzz I want to
thank all the nerdfighters who made
illustrations of Gus I'm sorry I
couldn't include more of them and I want
to thank you all for having the decency
not to abuse Gus rubs his fuzz Gus rubs
and rubs in the way that you might have
I also want to thank the nerdfighter who
made this illustration Gus is not a bug
Gus is a de NOS plexippus larvae thanks
for keeping me honest and reminding me
that Smart is cooler than cute hank
dftba I'll see you on Monday